did this life
me why would you bet on Goliath when we
got bet David valueing giv values
contagious this world of entrepreneurs
we get no value to ha run homie look
what I become I'm I'm the
one okay today episode 351 we have with
us Dr John Abrams
he's an American physician and the
author of books overdosed America the
broken promise of American Medicine and
sickening how big Pharma broke American
healthc care and how we can repair it he
has worked as a family doctor in appasia
and in Hamilton massachusett and has
served as chairman of the department of
family practice at Ley Clinic he was a
Robert Wood Johnson fellow in his on the
clinic faculty of Harvard Medical School
where he teaches primary care and public
health policy he graduated from Harvard
colge College 1974 he received an BMS
from Dartmouth Medical School followed
his MD with brown medical school he has
appeared on more than 65 national
television show shows including two
appear appearances on today's show as
well as Dr R but today what's more
important is he's been on Joe Rogan and
he's been on Lex Freedman and he's
written uh oped pieces for New York
Times LA Times and others and I'll read
the last part here on what he did what
his book uh the kind of influence his
book had so uh in September 2005 for
when he published overdosed America the
broken promise American Medicine just
one week later Vio was withdrawn in the
biggest drug recall ever but not before
it had already killed between 40 to
60,000 Americans despite providing no
better relief than inexpensive over
counter anti-inflamm inflammatory drugs
so having said that Doc it's great to
have you on the podcast it's a pleasure
to be here than me so we got a lot of
things I want to cover with you I got
some things with big farmer have an
issue with I've watched your podcast
with Lex I thought you guys did a great
job I thought he did a great job trying
to be fair and it was a perfect timing
because it was February of 2022 3 months
after he had interviewed the CEO of
fizer I believe two or three months and
I wonder how much your position changed
because when I was listening to that one
versus today and you know the great
thing
about medicine is it's constantly
evolving and my experience with medicine
has been my dad's 81 years old and he's
still alive because of folks from your
industry if it was for folks in your
industry he wouldn't be alive today one
of the best examples of uh uh the the uh
pharmaceutical industry not only the
pharmaceutical industry the health the
doctor industry uh Ken langon which I'm
sure you're familiar with billionaire
Home Depot there's a NYU I believe even
has a hospital named after him and he's
in his mid 80s early 80s I want to say
he looks like he's 70 but he's oh shoot
I'm F 88 years old and in his book I
love capitalism he tells a story on how
his dad I believe died at 60 or 62 years
old can you search to see what age Ken
lon's father died he died at 60 or maybe
even 58 years old and he says all my dad
needed was blood inners if my dad had
blood inners he would be alive today he
says I'm 80 some years old because I've
been taking blood thinners for so many
years that was a simple little invention
that you know patent that they came up
with and that helped my you know my dad
would have been around today or who
would have lived longer so there's a lot
of positive things in it but there's
also a lot of people filled with egos
who hate to be wrong because let's face
it in our space like I was a financial
adviser working on Morgan Stanley Dean
witer and I went to Trans America World
Financial and I would sit with people
who are doctors if if I tell you which
professional knew the least about money
it was doctors doctors knew nothing
about money and every time I asked them
I said how do you this is all you got I
do man how is it that smart people like
you don't have your finances is an order
he says just because we're doctors
everybody thinks we know everything and
we don't we don't know everything about
money so how much has your position
change from February of
200222 when you were with Lex at that
time we were still all learning about
the side effects of vaccine you guys on
that on that uh podcast talked about
vaccine you were talking about had you
had take them taken a vaccine you're
somebody that Pro vaccine you had gone
through it and then conversation came
about censorship because of what Joe was
going through at the time with Spotify
and all that stuff and you said I think
I'm more I'm less inclined to antivaxers
being allowed to speak freely on social
media platforms than those who are
qualified to talk about it how much of
what you talked about then has changed
two years later being today good
question um so I think there's two
questions there one is about vaccines
the other is about um the risk of having
people conclude that what I'm saying is
don't take medicine m medicin don't work
they're not worth the money shut it down
that's absolutely not my position and uh
if I can tell you a little story uh I
had a life-threatening illness uh I had
a recurrent ventricular tacac cardia
that got progressively worse over about
eight years and I got to the end of the
line I was stuck in the hospital on IV
lidocaine if the dose was turned down I
would go into ventricular tachicardia I
had had three failed to BL
and it was the end of the L how old were
you it was last year 15 months ago got
it um I got transferred into uh one of
the teaching hospitals at Boston where
they do a very complicated procedure
they go in the groin into a regular as
if it were a regular blazion and at the
same time another dock goes through the
chest wall and threads a little catheter
into the lining of your heart so that
two electronic monitors can work at the
at the same time and they can find the
source of the arhythmia in three
dimensions when you just go in the groin
you can just get it in two dimensions on
the surface you don't know how deep it
is and my problem happened to be right
on the outside of the heart they would
have had to perforate my heart to get it
from the inside but they got it from the
outside six-h hour procedure by two
worldclass docks and they Sav my life
the next day a cardiologist comes into
my room and starts telling me I should
be taking more col cerol lowering
medicine and I said wait a minute the
you know that's not the issue and the
study he knows you're a doctor he knows
I'm a doctor I I don't know whether he
knows what that I write about this and
that I've written articles about it but
he knows I'm a doctor and I say to him
look the study that you're citing is not
a good study it has bad endpoints and um
and he said well if it if you restricted
the endpoints to good endpoints it would
cost the company too much to do the
study and I said well that's not my
problem that's the company's problem if
they can't do the study then they
shouldn't be selling the drug and uh
then I said besides which do you know
I'm looking him in the eye and I can
also see the monitor I don't know that
I'm cured yet and I'm watching the heart
monitor as the tension Rises and I say
to him do you know that when peer
reviewers review articles for the best
journals jamama the New England Journal
do you know that those peer reviewers
don't get to see the real data from the
studies they just get to see the data
that has been put into the 10 page
manuscript that was submitted to the
journal and the peer reviewers don't
know what happened in the study do you
know that and he said yes I do and I
said to him if you know that the
evidence that doctors have to rely on
the evidence and evidence-based medicine
has not been vetted with a thorough
independent analysis of the data how can
you possibly present yourself as a
learned intermediary and recommend the
these treatments to other doctors and to
your
patients and that was the end of the
conversation what did he say to you he
just he he I can't remember but he now
is this a cardiolog I mean you wouldn't
just go to any card is this a well-known
cardiologist you went to or just a
cardiologist no no no I'm I'm in one of
the uh world class teaching hospitals at
Harvard yeah okay yeah so he's a trusted
guy that's going through this so for you
H why don't you as a person that's going
to Harvard you know uh uh you know
Hospital why don't you trust him why
don't you take his
recommendation because he knows that he
doesn't have access to the data that he
is drawing his conclusions from and yet
he's willing to make recommendations
with inadequate data why is he giving it
to you don't know one you're a doctor he
doesn't he knows he doesn't have the
data he knows nobody has the data you
have to be in litigation to get the data
dat he knows that and yet he's willing
to participate in this system where peer
review is meaningless yet doctors have
to practice in accord with EV so-called
evidence-based medicine so who is he
whose orders is he following is this the
FDA is the is it the hospital's
guidelines is it whose guidelines is he
following yeah good question so what
he's following is really um there was
this wonderful book written by a nuclear
physicist turned philosopher of science
Thomas in 1962 wrote a book called
the structure of scientific revolutions
and what he showed is that when there
are experts who rely on a certain body
of knowledge you can't you're not
allowed to become an expert unless you
adhere to the unwritten rules of the
legitimacy of the science and that this
is coming to play in American Medicine
the docs even the academic leaders like
like the the cardiologist I was talking
to believe that somehow there's this
magical transformation of non vetted
data into real evidence that he should
trust and recommend for his patients and
for the doctors he's
teaching it's it's the the the what
appears to be the truth of the science
is sociologically determined it's not
scientifically determined can I ask you
a question as I was reading that part
you know in I read a summary of your
book and what you were saying here and I
was trying to convert it into an
understanding for the common man I'd
like to know what you if you think my
understanding is correct so Pat writes a
book a deep research book I am the first
person so I see the whole book all of
his research all of his appendices and I
write a book
review you write what's called a peer
review most people think well another
learned doctor must have gone through
everything and is writing a peer review
but in fact you wrote your peer review
only on my book report you never read
Pat's book is that a good understanding
of what you're describing for the common
person it is but it's worse let's
translate the pat Pat's book and uh the
review into clinical practice guidelines
which doctors have to follow they get
presented uh in court if things go AR
the people who write those clinical
practice guidelines are relying on the
studies that have been published in the
journals those Studies have been
peer-reviewed but the data hasn't been
analyzed when they write their when the
guidelines are written the experts who
write those guidelines just have access
to the articles that are published they
don't have access to the real data so to
go back to your analogy you'd be writing
if I relied on a review that wouldn't be
good but if I relied on Patrick's
references which is what the experts do
who write the guid lines that tell
doctors how to practice that doesn't
work either because that's not uh
independently analyzed data God this is
crazy so now I write the book review
five other doctors do a peer review of
my book review and then a six doctor has
access to that and only that and starts
writing the how-to procedure for
emergency rooms and doctors to perform
you've got it so let me go back to the
question and none of those people go
back to Pat's original book but Pat's
original book isn't going to be good
enough they don't but that's not good
enough because what Pat has relied on
being a meticulous researcher is the
articles that have been published in the
academic literature in medicine those
articles the peer review is a sham so
it's all built on Sand so he may have
written his book wa a
minute all the papers are all built on
sham all the papers are peer reviewed
the peer reviewers don't have access
access to the data the drug companies
own the
data okay so so then let me go back to
the question I was asking you so you're
on the inside we're not okay okay but
but for you you know within your space
just like there is within politics or
within the military there are
anti-establishment
generals or Colonels or lieutenants you
know like if you watched a movie Scent
of a Woman that was an establishment
Colonel right you know who I'm talking
about you Robert alpacino phenomenal
crushed it right so okay you go in uh
the uh political side there's
anti-establishment candidates some would
say Kennedy's were anti-establishment
some will say I'm talking johnf Kennedy
not RFK but even RFK could be
anti-establishment some may say Trump
may be as anti-establishment there's
anti-establishment candidates right but
then there's the establishment side you
were part of the establishment for many
years right and and let me kind of ask
the question push back tear my argument
apart whatever you want that's the whole
reason why we're having this
conversation one may say you were
establishment you practice you follow
the guidelines you followed the laws you
followed the rules you followed all that
stuff did you during covid doc at all
have a moment where you're like what the
hell is going on here like what are they
forcing down people to take this with
this much research and we don't have the
right kind of research and look at the
numbers that's coming up and why are
they not willing to release this why are
they putting such a long time for us not
to get the data on this why is it that
we can't sue these guys why is it was
there ever a moment during Co for you
was like a Tipping Point yes there was
but let me just go back and finish up
our last conversation about peer review
there was a wonderful article it was
published in the New England Journal
actually and it looked at the terms of
the contracts between academic medical
centers and the drug companies so only
about a quarter of the studies are done
in academic medical centers the rest are
done in for-profit by for-profit
research companies but the ones that are
done in the academic medical centers are
going to be the highest quality studies
50% 50 literally 50% of those contracts
gave the drug companies the right to
write up the results of the research and
the
authors
were suppressed to the point where they
had the right to suggest revisions but
they couldn't make revisions the drug
company controlled the article
50% who allows that you can't do that
without the help of the government
though you don't need the government
what you need is a market that's not
functioning because the drug companies
had pulled so much research out of the
academic medical centers and the
academic medical centers needed that
money Managed Care was coming in while
this was happening they didn't have a
lot of money in their pocket okay they
needed to attract that research money as
much as they could they ended up with
about 25% of the research but it was the
market because the contract research
organizations were willing to abide by
those uh regulations that academic
medical centers had to so it was the it
was a dysfunctional Market that was
allowing the drug companies to write up
50% of these articles and the peer
review was a sham there was no way to
get to the bottom of it yeah but isn't
there a chairman of the board or a
committee that's going to come in and
say what the hell are you guys doing
because at this point that means the
doctors and the writers are slaves to
these big pharmaceutical companies and
those are the ones that are making the
big decisions for them and they they're
telling them what to do is that kind of
what it comes down to that's what it
comes down to so I I was at a medical
meeting and uh I was sitting near an
editor not editor-in Chief but a major
editor of a major journal and the
meeting was over and we got up uh to
walk out and I said to him uh listen why
don't you guys demand the data from the
trials that you're going to
publish it's pretty simple the data is
there they could deliver it to you it's
thing called a clinical study reports
like 3,000 pages long they they've
already done it they could they could
deliver it uh you could require it with
the manuscript and he said to me before
I took the next step he said requiring
that data would be a death spiral for
the journal and what he's saying is if
we require data and other journals don't
require the data
the companies won't submit their big
articles to us and a major part of the
income of the journals wow a major part
of the income of the journals comes from
selling reprints back to the company for
their drug reps to hand out and in 2005
41% of the lancet's income came from
selling reprints that's the last data
there is so he was admitting to me in in
sort of poetically e economic language
that they're in the business the the
financial model that they're in is
selling reprints back to the drug
companies and they can't behave in a way
that's going to decrease their their
sales of those of of those articles at
what point were were these data like was
access to data available and did an
event happen to cause this data to be
hidden for example you know when you
think about uh uh some of the acts that
they come up with every industry has all
these acts in the financial industry
Investment Company Act of 1940 or all
this other stuff right right so there's
one here where uh uh in 1986 the
national childhood vaccine injury Act
Right
ncvia became law Y and what this did is
it it waved any liability for
pharmaceutical companies and vaccine
manufacturers for injuries or death
caused by vaccine 86 that's roughly 40
years ago a little less than 40 years
ago right okay was there a time where
data was available to the consumer to
know and researchers and doctors to look
at at where big Pharma came in hiring a
lobbyist firm to work with a Congress or
Senate to pass something that that data
doesn't need to be available to the
public again no it evolved slowly
because the drug companies were doing
this um but they didn't have complete
control of the situation because 80% of
the research was being done in academic
Med in academic centers so the academic
docs were seeing it so this situation
developed slowly and now there's an
organization called the international
Committee of medical Journal editors 13
uh the 13 biggest General Medical
journals in the world they would be the
body that would do this but they've been
tiptoeing in place who's funding them
they're the journals the the they are
the journals so who's funding them is uh
the sale of reprints and their
subscribers who owns them uh their own
it's I'm looking at them right now here
parent organization and international
Committee of so it's themselves it's
International Committee of jours
Vancouver group
formerly okay so they're purely not
releasing all the information because
they're worried it could hurt their
Topline Revenue correct it'll it'll hurt
their impact factor it'll hurt their
reprint sales some of these journals are
nonprofits uh the New England Journal is
a nonprofit the journal American Medical
how many of these guys are out there how
many how many these journals oh there
are a million journals but these are the
13 big ones so the 13 big ones who are
they all independent nonprofits no no
the L that's owned by ele so so if none
of them are giving the data then they're
all on the same page together so and why
is that is it kind of like you know how
they say you know every single Media
company is really owned by five families
you know how you read those kind of
articles that come out are are the same
people running these 13 different
organizations or no they're all 13
separate basically there are some
journals that are different the British
medical journal it's now called the bmj
is different uh they but they're not as
commercially involved but the biggest
journals are playing in this financial
Arena where the editors have a fiduciary
responsibility to maximize their profits
and they're doing it yeah but who's
exposing them who is calling them out
who is CH like for example at least if I
have a New York Times I got a New York
Post right if I got a wapo Washington
Post I got a Washington Times right and
they're going to be opposing each other
in the business side if I got a Forbes I
got a fortune I got an entrepreneur I
got an Inc I got a business week I got a
different guys that maybe will be
challenging each I got CNN I got Fox I
got MSNBC there's competition right you
mean to tell me there's nobody that's
calling these guys out to they're
Patrick that's why I'm sitting here the
mainstream media has put the lid on this
nobody's covering it nobody is covering
this it's a tragedy and we haven't even
started to talk about the cost and the
poor health of Americans that is largely
tied into this this is market failure
you know Milton fredman the ultimate
capitalist said that there are three
things a government should do it should
preserve law and order it should um make
enforce private contracts and it should
make sure markets work he said that in
1962 in his book capitalism and freedom
and if we would go back to those three
principles and apply them to the
pharmaceutical industry and what's going
on in healthcare we would take a giant
step forward away from this so it sounds
like you're saying that the business
model is all wrong because if I if I'm
creating a a medical journal I'm not
getting paid subscriptions from a bunch
of doctors and want to read that what
you're saying is the most that if I
publish uh articles that are in line
with what the Pharmaceuticals want they
say hey thanks for the nice article
thanks for everything that goes with
that I'll take 10,000 copies of it and
then I'm going to go give them to my
sales reps to hand them out to America's
uh allergist if I'm making an allergy
draw you're saying that's the business
model it's not thousands and thousands
of doctors paying subscription because
if it was Forbes would compete with
fortune and business people would
subscribe to one or the other based
which they think is better information
you're saying that they're really not
operating Publications they're operating
printing services that are reprinting
articles for the medical establishment
driven by the pharmaceutical company
correct there there is some subscription
fees but there not the major thing the
major thing the major sources of income
are selling reprints and selling
advertising to the manufacturers but
then to me then to me this is what it
comes down to who has brass to call them
out who has brass to talk about it and
why don't the mainstream media people
talk about it for example yesterday
today we reacted to Charles Barkley
being pissed off are you football guy
you follow the NFL okay he's pissed off
about the fact that one of the main
games was on peacock I think it was what
Miami Dolphins against Kansas City or
what whichever game I was pissed off too
okay so but you know what to me you know
what I said I said I love it and let me
tell you why because it kind of
validates your point he was pissed off
saying how could you do this and I
understand it's all about money
apparently they got $110 million from
Peacock by the way peacock got a 23
million viewers that watched it
record-breaking ever right but why am I
happy about it this is why I'm happy
about I kind it's going to go back to
you because these peacocks Amazon
Netflix of the world they rely on
monthly subscription fee they don't rely
on advertisers they rely mainly on
monthly subscription fees okay cable TV
relies on what advertisers and we know
who's their biggest Advertiser I think
cable TV is staying in business for
three different reasons Sports Boomers
and big Pharma okay so the more they
step away the less big Pharma can
control just the other day Travis Kelce
uh uh they reported if you can pull this
up right
that fiser you know how much fiser paid
him to do the uh covid vaccine
commercial million $20 million right 20
million doll so for every one of these
guys and you're seeing their Topline
Revenue what they're doing who's not
afraid of them to call them out who's
not afraid of big Pharma the journals
what's taking place so just come out and
say guys you're getting exposed who's
that person or
organization it's you and it's other
people who are trying to get um to to to
fill in what mainstream media is not
willing to do mainstream media is not
willing to talk about this so Travis
Kelly gets $20 million and he also has
this relationship with Taylor Swift and
God knows what how that unfolded um but
here's the story to get back to your
question about
covid I I was with the program during
the early phases during operation warp
speed when uh the Republicans were
throwing money at the drug companies
tons of money money to get it out to get
the vaccine out most quickly we didn't
know how bad this was going to be it
wasn't you had to look and see if there
were real warning signs but it looked
like it was safe at least in the short
term and I was with the program but now
we've had three different boosters
coming on and Travis kelse is on TV
advertising the third booster um there's
been No randomized Control Data to
support the use of those
boosters now that's just not okay the
FDA is approving these boosters with all
the um advocacy of the CDC and the
experts um who speak on TV um saying get
the boosters and we just don't know what
the effect of the boosters is we can go
into the details of it if if you want
but we don't know I'm of a certain age
and I had a hard condition hopefully
it's cured I'm worried I get the
boosters but I don't have data you got
all three of them I got all three of
them but I don't have data that tells me
it's okay why did you get them I got
them cuz uh the arhythmia that I had
that's now suppressed could be uh
reactivated uh with Co that went to the
heart arhythmia that you have that could
be reactivated that went to the heart
yeah tell me what that means so I I I
told you the story about being in theit
15 months ago yes yeah yeah and having
this uh aym you did an angel went up and
also from the front yeah absolutely yeah
so I was at death store I mean I I I
made my piece I was ready to go um and
this is serious
business I'm in a different risk benefit
situation than most people are I'm also
75 so I'm in a different risk benefit uh
situation so without randomized Control
Data just with uh antibody data and an
and observational data the second
booster was actually approved with
antibody data fizer's uh vaccine was
approved with antibody data from eight
mice and madna did much better than that
they had antibody data from ten mice
this is the SEC the second vaccine we
have twice the data sir well not but 25%
more yeah
um it's I'm telling the truth and the
FDA is letting this go on and the CDC is
picking it up um so there's no data
there's not data that it's bad there's
not data that it works and I I'm going
to play my odds by getting the booster
knowing that I don't know what I'm
getting but you're young you guys are
young and healthy and you may look at
this situation and say wait a minute
there's no data we don't know long-term
effects we don't know if it prevents
hospitalizations or uh serious illness
and you're not likely to get seriously
ill if you get covid and you may decide
I'm going to pass until they get some
good data out here that I can decide on
I never got it so I didn't get it my
wife didn't get get it well our kids
didn't get it but my dad who's 81 today
he got the vaccine and got all the
boosters uh so did my nanny who lives
with us been with us for 14 years she's
in her 60s they chose to get it and we
totally supported them and we ran a
insurance company where we had to decide
what guys wanted to do and I said you do
what you want to do with your body I'm
healthy I'm and I got covid my wife got
covid we all went through it it was you
know the process we went through but go
go 70% of America's vaccinated if you
type in Rob what percentage of Americans
are vaccinated I want to say it's
somewhere between 67 to
71% are vaccinated you may know these
numbers better than I do can you zoom in
a little bit what percentage of
Americans are vaccinated 70% of
Americans are give or take vaccinated
and if you get to older folks the
percentage is higher higher right so
based on what you know now and you 75
years old you said I accepted I made the
decision this is serious business right
15 months ago this may be it for me
right you're 73 74 years old
so now that you know what you know where
do we go wrong what mistakes did we make
who should have never taken it all the
Late Night show forcing everybody to
take it and Military being forced to
retire or else and you know Bill M the
other day is like I took one for the
team I never wanted to take it he had
Seth McFarland on he's debating him he
had Jimmy Kimel on he's deting debating
him all of these guys were forced to so
many we had a guy that was a colonel
before in the military he got kicked out
cuz they didn't want to take the vaccine
he's sitting here telling us to Story
how many of those stories that we have
to hear where did we go wrong when it
comes down to the vaccine well let's go
uh last do the last first it's very
simple with the boosters if we're going
to have a booster campaign and we're
going to recommend that Americans get it
and we're going to use public media uh
uh Public Service Media to advertise it
and create um try to create an
imperative you need randomized control
trials that's what science is so the
first booster was done on observational
data from Israel uh one out of 17 people
took the booster Israel approved the
booster early and it was a perfect
situation where you could do a
randomized control trial it was not
known whether it worked or not uh Israel
was first in line and they could have
easily gotten hundreds of thousands of
people to go into a randomized control
trial and could have produced data early
that's not what fizer did I think it was
fizer um what they did is they they
uh they harvested data from the
electronic medical records and they
compared the death rate from covid in
the people who chose to get the booster
to the death rate from covid in people
who did not choose to get the booster
and they found that there was a 94%
lower covid death rate in the people who
chose to get the booster that was
published in the New England Journal it
became evidence-based medicine everyone
had to get a booster and and that that
was the truth the scientific truth and
you couldn't challenge it
what came out just recently is that when
you look at that same population of
people 94% fewer deaths from covid and
94% fewer deaths from non-co illnesses
in other words those people were 94%
less likely to die of anything they were
healthier you can't do an observational
study because the people who choose to
get a shot are different than the people
who choose not to get a shot now the FDA
knows this well I mean this whole thing
about hormone replacement that went
crazy in the 80s and '90s that we got it
wrong and women millions of women took
hormone replacement therapy increasing
their risk of breast cancer and now it
turns out dementia as well because it
was observational data and the women who
took the hormone replacement therapy
were healthier because they were going
to be healthier in the first place and
you could say that you could find the
women who are going to be healthier by
just seeing which ones chose to take
hormone replacement therapy therapy or
not so the FDA has been through this
many times they know that observational
data are not
reliable I don't get it why the FDA does
not insist on randomized control trials
when they approve new vaccines and and
tell people they should get them so
let's let's ask this question okay so
FDA is an organization that regulates
and approves American companies American
Pharmaceutical compan companies right
okay we have 195 countries give or take
five right what other countries are
stricter there's only two companies that
if you were to say what the dollar thing
is really in there you know this you've
spoken about this New Zealand and us you
know New Zealand did in 1980 I want to
take give or take when they're like yeah
you know what moving forward we can
advertise on TV and us is saying hey
there's a big difference
between a big farm on nicotine and Cigar
Company cigarette company why do we drop
maror why are we not doing Winston
what's the big difference well you know
because over here this is actually can
help the other one cannot help okay fine
that's your argument great I don't agree
with it but fine but there's 193 other
countries that can sit there and say no
let's make the best educated decision
there is not the level of big
pharmaceutical profits being made
there're like we are what are they doing
what are you noticing other countries
doing that are saying no no we're not
with this right who is fully against the
way we've been handling Pharmaceuticals
in America okay so New Zealand's the
other country that does directed
consumer advertising so it's interesting
to compare the two New Zealand has a
very active pharmaceutical National
pharmaceutical program they oversee
which drugs are approved and they
evaluate the comparative effectiveness
of different drugs so this is a good
test in the United States because we're
the wild west of drug marketing and TV
advertising we spend by far the most on
drugs of any of the wealthy countries
New Zealand has direct to Consumer
advertising they spend the least of the
wealthy countries on their
drugs so even
though the countries have access to the
same data the national drug policy makes
a huge difference and this is where we
may disagree but there needs to be some
kind of uh federal or quasy governmental
oversight of the information that the
doctors and the public gets about drugs
we don't have that we're the only
wealthy country that doesn't have that
so that we've got the same bad
information and I don't know why the
other countries haven't insisted on uh
randomized control trials but we got the
same bad information but we in the
United States it's much more effective
at convincing doctors and patients to
take the drugs uh without getting the
information that New Zealand's going to
offer to their citizens if you ask the
average fairly informed person person
and you just gave the description you
had of New Zealand the average informed
person in America I would think would
say wait a minute what you're just
describing in New Zealand isn't that
what the FDA is supposed to be doing
what's the difference between am I right
so what's the difference between what
the FDA really does and what is
happening in New Zealand okay this is
really important the fda's job is to
evaluate data about new drugs and to
determine excuse me which of those drugs
have statistically significant efficacy
and no evidence of harm that's greater
than that excuse me and and ultimately
approve them for General use approve
them for General use and doctors can't
be uh can't prescribe the drugs unless
they're approved by the FDA but the FDA
does not inform doctors about how that
drug compares to the best existing
therapy and how many uh um it does
doesn't inform doctors about where that
drug fits into optimal therapy that's
not the fda's job other countries have
another another organization that does
that we don't so is that what you were
describing New Zealand does yes yes and
uh we're tiptoeing into it but the
political headwinds I think are going to
sink it the uh FDA approves drugs the
center for Medicaid Medicare and
Medicaid services is claiming the right
to evaluate the efficacy the benefits
and harms in the real world of clinical
practice to determine whether they're
going to cover the drugs that the FDA
approves um and we can talk about a
cover you mean CM CMS most people know
what CMS is oh CMS they make decisions
it affects my Medicare Medicaid and and
and my costs so you're saying CMS says
hey we'll cover this drug for um skin
allergies of some sort we're going to
cover it so CMS says you're going to
cover it and then a bunch of retired
people say yay it's covered by Medicare
now I can take that drug correct correct
that's CMS CMS and CMS is claiming the
right uh and it's been supported in
court to say that drug has not been
proven to be effective uh for this
population and therefore we're not going
to cover it for either for General use
or for any use and we're headed towards
a political confrontation on this so let
me let me see if I translate that so CMS
is saying if I don't if we don't think
this drug is good for the skin allergy
we're not going to prove it we're not
going to pay for it translation taxpayer
isn't going to pay for it under Medicaid
for all these retired people I mean
Medicare for all these reti people that
have have Medicare in fact this there's
a showdown coming because are you about
to say this is what the FDA thinks its
job is and that's where the Showdown is
between CMS and FDA or something else no
there's no question that the FDA that's
not the fda's job and it's important to
understand that so where's The Showdown
there that you're talking The Showdown
is going to come uh there's a a new drug
to treat early Alzheimer's disease
called LMI and this drug could could
cost so much that it actually uh equals
the total amount of money that Medicare
B spends annually on drugs it's cost
$26,000 a year and another
$882,000 for clinical oversight and
monitoring CMS is saying we're not going
to cover this drug unless you collect
data in a registry so that soon we'll
know how effective this drug is the
clinical trial upon which the FDA relied
showed that it was statistically
significant but it didn't reach it the
efficacy didn't reach being clinically
significant um and the the fda's job is
to do it on um on statistical
significance statistical significance
not clinical benefit so CMS is taking
this problem which could cost the
taxpayers a fortune $40 billion a year
um and CMS is saying okay FDA approved
it we're going to cover it but we're
only going to cover it if you put if
doctors put the data in a registry so
that that sounds like good public policy
what happened is CMS has a registry
that's going to collect the data that
they need to figure out uh whether the
Drug's working and whether it's doing
more good than harm CMS has has
developed those criteria in the label it
says you need to uh you should enter
your patient in reg in a registry but it
doesn't say enter them in the CMS
registry it says enter them in the
allnet registry the allnet registry is
sponsored by the Alzheimer's Foundation
the two biggest cont contributors to the
uh pharmaceutical contributors to the
Alzheimer's Foundation are the two drug
companies that are making these new
drugs that are fantastically expensive
and the allnet uh registry is going to
pay doctors pay doctors 2500 bucks for
signing up for this and $300 per visit
for every visit that they register in
the allset registry so all in that
registry is going to buy its way over
the CMS registry and now this drug
company sponsored organization is going
to be determining what data they collect
and how they're going to uh report it so
you know what this makes me think about
is the following way so you're saying
the only people that really have access
to everything all the data is the
pharmaceutical companies right they have
the data and in litigation Patrick which
is why I'm sitting here because I spent
10 or 12 years in in pharmaceutical
litigation in litigation as an expert
you sign a confidentiality agreement
okay and you get access to the computer
hard drives from the from the drug
companies you get everything and I know
what's in there and that's why that's
how I learned how important this stuff
is because I know you guys are sitting
there saying this guy Abramson is
telling this wild Story how the hell do
I know that I mean it's just a crazy
story and why isn't it told oh no no I
believe it I just I just wonder why it
hasn't why so so for example financial
industry okay uh what's the one word
stock Brokers cannot use with their
clients that gets them in trouble it's a
g-l word hey Mr and Mrs Johnson I
guarantee you a 12% rate of return da on
this mutual fund right so
okay okay you coughed I'm coughing Tom
you're next so hopefully you're ready
for it you want me to cough or so no
you're good yeah wait a wait a minute so
the question becomes the following right
there's this thing called the stock
market you can go out there and tell me
how well your stock is doing but the
stock market tells me how well you're
doing
and there's this thing called quarterly
earnings that I can get quarterly
earnings and say hey your quarterly
earnings you expected to do this you
miss the mark and your stock goes 5%
drops for day and hey here's what
they're doing hey such and such a
shorting your company Kathy Wood or xyza
you know icon ion is shorting AIG and
they want the co to be fired oh you
know whoever was was it Carl ion was
shorting whoever the co was AIG right
and ping Square was shorting Herbal Life
so there's big players there's big
players that's Amman I believe and Amman
and icon got into it so correct but
there's at least we the public sees it
and says wait a minute what was that all
about why is this stock doing this hey
you know I'd like to recommend you
Investment Company Act of American
mutual fund with American Funds this
fund has been around since 1934 can I I
see the perspectus sure here's what the
perspectus looks like da d d da okay
this year was a big drop off what
happened the last 5 years your five-e
rate of return Isn't 12% and then you
have to explain yourself and the you
know the financial adviser does why why
isn't somebody
enforcing big pharmaceutical companies
to give data on exactly what happened
with these covid vaccinations what
happened with the results how many
injuries do we have what really took
place everybody is just trying to delay
it right delay it delay it and even
recent ly the story comes out with uh um
with Anthony fouchy saying the fact that
where is the story I think it's this one
right here saying the fact that um
fouche's former boss concedes Co lab
leak was not a conspiracy theory that's
just a story that came out yesterday
right and fouchi is out there using the
legendary line uh which I don't recall I
don't recall I don't recall I don't
recall I don't recall Dr Francis Collins
do you know Dr Francis Collins former
head of the NIH testified in a closed
door session with the house coronavirus
subcommittee admitting that the co lab
leak theory was credible this marks a
significant shift from his earlier
characterization of its very destructive
conspiracy house Republican leading the
hearing revealed that Dr Collins
acknowledged The credibility of the leak
hypothesis contradicting fouche's
previous stance they also accused both
doctors of using their influence to
pressure researchers and to favoring a
natural origin Theory over the lab leak
Theory regarding CO's origin I mean
people are sitting there saying wait a
minute we bought that it wasn't we
bought that it wasn't so why isn't there
an organization or institution that's
forcing these guys to give us the data
okay two answers one is there's an
office of the Inspector General report
that was filed in January of 2023 okay
the office of the Inspector General
found that um there was a grant from the
NIH to Eco Health in 200
14 and some of that money went to the
Wuhan uh Institute of
iology but Obama had put a ban on gain
of function
research so they couldn't do gain of
function research Eco Health filed its
reports with the NIH through
2017 when Trump came in he lifted the
ban on gain of function research meaning
making viruses more virulent and more
dangerous he lifted the ban and Ecco
Health stopped filing reports uh to the
NIH and there are no reports that were
filed after the gain of function ban was
lifted and the NIH had to know that they
didn't have the reports and this is this
office of the Inspector General you can
Google it uh report is out there so we
were funding research and we didn't know
what the research was doing so let me
let me ask Sarah so you just answered
what happened in that case in the
financial services industry prospectuses
are everywhere and it's law they have to
be out there and people that saw the
popular movie uh The Big Short you can
see Michael bu uh the somewhat
challenged but genius uh from uh San
Jose California says I've read the full
report I know the mortgages are in here
I looked at several samples and
ultimately the Steve Carroll character
takes the same report goes down to South
Florida and checks out some
neighborhoods so when the financial
services industry the answer is the law
is that in some of these perspectives is
the complete data is available you just
answered what happened with that
particular report the question is what
is preventing what law is there or is
there and written poorly that this
information is not available to maybe a
research physician like Michael bur that
wants to look at it so where's where is
that problem right now we're narrowing
in on the real problem
and the problem is that the drug
company's job they're Executives because
they're paid largely in stock options
and stocks their investors the private
Equity firms the hedge funds their job
is to maximize the profits that are
derived from the pharmaceutical industry
sure and this is the moral hazard but
where's the law that would say hey if
you're going to have this research
report and they're going to be peer
reviewed somewhere there has to be the
Magna Carta the Rosetta Stone the
original research and stuff that goes
with it how is that not available is
there no law that says it has to be it's
not available I I one of the slides I
sent you was fizer talking about data
and they're saying scientific data um
the drug company fizer owns the data
they're not going to release the data
and furthermore they admit very bluntly
that the purpose of the data is to
support their marketing not to improve
the health of americ an but to support
their marketing so this the business
side of this has taken over and the
scientific oversight has been whittel
away by the profit motive the profits
that are going to the academic medical
centers and to the academic researchers
and to the drug companies and to the
journals and to the nonprofits um that
are accepting pharmaceutical money and
what we've got is this massive market
failure where money is coloring what
doctors think think they know about
Healthcare and this is a real problem I
mean you guys tell me you're you're much
more into financial markets that I am
but my understanding is that when you
get a market failure of this magnitude
you need government to come in and
straighten it out got it so in financial
services I'm one of the big Banks uh
bare Sterns and I own the data that was
in that that um that mortgage that
mortgage fund that that covering fund
basically you know a mut mutual fund of
all the mortgages but the law says that
I had to make all that data available I
own the data I own that this is my
product that I'm selling to people this
Mutual they're buying okay what you're
saying in Pharmaceuticals MC May own the
data but there's no law out there that
says MC has to make that available to
other doctors or anybody for expansion
that's exactly right so no president on
the left or the right has forc them to
give that data to the public ex okay so
let's go back to this there's the what
I'm looking at this here do you trust Dr
Anthony fouchy do I trust him um I saw
Dr fouchy get out over a skis with the
initial vaccine um saying it was safe
when it had only been used for two
months and nobody could know whether it
was safe um I think they implied that it
would decrease transmissibility and that
would justify the mandates I think that
was not in in the data so I think at
that point I thought he was like an
overly zealous Boy Scout who thought he
was doing the right thing uh by
overselling uh beyond the knowledge uh
the vaccines at this point with the with
the with the boosters not having any
randomized control trials I don't know
what's going on there something's going
on there I don't know what it is how the
US government can allow the FDA to
accept to to approve these boosters and
to Market them as actively as they do
with no randomized control trials
completely escapes me I don't get it you
know you know what confuses me a little
bit I'm curious to know what you'll say
about this because when I'm looking at
the data here uh the same person we're
talking about NIH director Francis
Collins formalized collaboration with
the Chinese Academy of military science
in 2015 under Obama according to the
book and shared a photo that he uh that
year of him with the Chinese Academy of
military Sciences president okay and
they're explaining what's going on here
and then you know Fouch is kind of like
I don't want to you know I'm not
involved we're not doing anything gay of
function isn't happening you've seen the
Rand Paul asking him over and over and
over and over and over
again here's here's where I'm at with
this year at that time you know
everybody is saying there's no way this
warp speed operation warp speed is going
to get done there's no way this is going
to take a year and a half camalo Harris
would you ever take the vaccine under
Trump I would never take it I would
never take a vaccine that's not tested
this is our vice president saying this
on TV
and what happens election is done two
days later the vaccine is available but
after the election exactly two days
later and then who promoted it to the
world everybody on the left sold it to
the world and if you didn't Twitter took
your videos down YouTube took your
videos down YouTube wouldn't let Peter
McCulla stuff stay up whether it's
Malone whether it's all of these guys
military took your job from your world
the industry you're a part of that all
supported at what fouchi was doing and
fouchi was God to people in the medical
world he could do anything wrong in the
face of anybody because God forbid if
you at all said anything fouchy did
wrong you would potentially be a
Republican and you can't be a republican
doc if you are labeled as a republican
that's a curse word to somebody like you
maybe right you're coming from Harvard I
went to Harvard OPM program this is when
I realize I will never go back to
Harvard let me explain it to you I'm at
Harvard op program for 3 weeks it's an
owner president Management program okay
I didn't go Harvard NBA like you went to
Harvard 7 1974 Harvard College as part
of Harvard I've never been anything with
Harvard it's just one of those executive
programs I go to guess what debate is
taking place while I'm there the
legendary debate Trump against Hillary
I'm in Chia Hall you know where Chia
Hall is the the on the business side the
Asian billionaire who uh the the
restaurant the Chow where everybody eats
it's called chow hall his name is chow
hall right not Chow like military chow
hall when I was in I thought that's what
it was called but it's called his name
chow hall his picture is even in there I
say let me go watch this debate I go and
and watch a debate I'll see all the
teachers all the professors that work at
this incredible Institute called Harvard
and 100% of them booed Trump and 100% of
them cheered for Hillary you know what I
realized happened to Harvard they're all
deaf
because they're all around the same
people that all agree with them here's
an institution with $60 billion of
endowment cash sitting there for them
who all agree with each other that's
when I realized that's no longer a
university that's an echo chamber it's
not a university and this is why when
you know you're thinking there's so much
about the people and all this other
stuff unfortunately for myself you know
you're like well now that everybody's
not allowed to come to school on on
campus do we still have to pay the same
amount of tuition to come to school cuz
we're not using boarding we're not using
this you still do I said wait you still
want the students to pay for that yeah
so during Co the level of force from the
left the level of you do this or else
the level of silencing of the people
that simply disagree with you and by the
way it wasn't even non doctors and
non-experts there was a guy in
Bakersfield this one doctor that was
telling I'm just asking questions why
are we doing this why am I supposed to
put this death as a CO death this was
not a covid death but no you're supposed
to category put it the video gets 15
million views two doctors sitting there
video is taken down 24 hours later so
it's not like during that time you know
it was just the non-health experts that
were being silenced it was anybody that
disagreed with fouche's position was
being silenced right now it's 2024 do
you have anything to say about how the
left
mishandled Co led by Fouch policy cuz
Fouch is the one that was telling
everybody what's the right thing for us
to do and Trust the science and wear
three masks we're taking pictures with
masks then the pictures cameras comes
off everybody takes their mask off
people are not dummies sitting there
saying wait a minute don't patronize me
don't make me do something you don't
want to do but behind closed doors
you're doing it because it's a political
party that's what I saw in a you know
regular world I'm running an insurance
company with at our event we have 10,000
people at our event half our Democrats
half our Republicans but everybody was
like what the hell is going on here
these are valid concerns yeah your
thoughts absolutely uh there is a bias
on the left to support Public Health
measures it's a bias there's also
something going on with uh Drug Company
money and let me tell you a story that
will make some news in the Beyond uh the
story comes from the Boston Globe but it
hasn't gotten out and it is very new is
worthy and IT addresses exactly the
question you ask Claudine gay just got
fired as the president of Harvard
University she had plagiarized which I
think I'm not an expert on this but I
think that meant uh Missing quotation
marks and not citing
references um and that's not a good
thing an academic should not do that um
and uh she you sound like you're
defending her though let me finish my
story and you you won't be ready to
pounce on me okay I promise uh she gets
fired and Alan Garber who's been the
Provost of Harvard gets um appointed the
temporary
president okay so that's what happened
those are the facts Allan garber's
salary as Provost has been about
$940,000 a year I assume it's market
value I don't have a complaint since
2017 he's been on the board of two
pharmaceutical companies he's the
Provost of Harvard University and he's
been on the Board of two pharmaceutical
companies and his annual salary from
these two board positions is more than
his salary from Harvard it's $960,000
okay one of those two companies is
vertex Pharmaceuticals they're selling
their uh drug that is a revolutionary
drug that decreases the uh pulmonary
consequences of cystic fibrosis by about
14% And they're selling this drug for
$322,000 to it costs them to make less
than
$6,000 so we've got the Provost of
Harvard University in a position of
direct conflict of interest in talking
about the public health consequences of
this now this Hit me hard because I was
teaching I I'm not on the faculty
anymore but I I stepped down a year ago
uh but I was teaching Health Care policy
at Harvard for many years and one of the
case studies we taught all the first
year students in har at Harvard Medical
School was
if Medicaid ran out of
money what the the students in each
seminar group if Medicaid ran out of
money what services would you cut to
have the least impact to engage the
students with this great question yeah
and do you cut out eyeglasses every
other year do you cut out transportation
to doctors so forth what they didn't
talk about is that vertex's drug cost
$322,000 and cost $6,000 to make and
somebody ought to be negotiating with
these guys to get a fair price is that a
dosage or an annual annual so 360 if you
have got one if you got this terrible
rare Condition it's 330 Grand a month or
360 a year a little bit less probably 28
or 27 them okay but but that was an
annual figure and it cost six grand to
make yeah yes and and the um hepatitis
uh C Drugs that cost $11,000 a pill
$84,000 for a course of treatment and
they cost they're sold for $1,000 in
India where it's generic so what we've
got is this enormously unfair hyper
profitable situation we've got the
Provost of Harvard who's now the acting
president of pro Harvard sitting on two
boards and in health care policy they're
not teaching that you can't let the
market set these prices they're they
have monopol that makes sense to me why
Harvard would put somebody like that as
the board that makes sense to me cuz
Harvard's no longer a university
Harvard is no longer to me as a
university it makes sense for me to put
somebody there that owns them which is
another big can you pull up the article
of the top 10 most expensive and I want
to validate what he's saying here's the
top 10 most expensive drugs in America
as of January 15th per year hem genix
$3.5 million per one-time dose okay let
me say that one more time $3.5 million
per onetime dose go to the next person
go to the next one okay uh Elevate this
3.2 million you can go to the next one I
I I don't I don't disagree with this and
the price is awful it is important to
point out that these are one-time
treatments that I totally get it but
still $3 million oh my God this next one
sky Sona 3 million you can keep going L
just to kind of show the numers so when
he's saying $300,000 some people are
like that's a lot of money it's a one1
of many of these other 2.8 million
there's plenty we can go through here
but again to go back to the question you
made about I'm trying to see the point
you were trying to make so were you
trying to say you know because Claudine
gay was a Dei hire that's what she was
she was a DI hire because she was a
woman and she was African-American and
nowadays you get extra points when you
hire somebody with di because the money
people are very happy with you when you
do something like that there's a big Fe
right now United uh uh uh uh
Airlines CEO is talking about the fact
that they're Pilots the goal is to have
50% of them
be women and of color why do we care
about hiring based on women and of color
what if these girls don't want to be
Pilots when they grow up what if there's
a bigger percentage out of a 100 Kids
100 boys say 30% want to be Pilots when
they grow up 100 girls under the age of
12 maybe three want to be Pilots when
they grow up why are you trying to
change that if that doesn't make sense
so that's my problem with Harvard but
let me go back to it again everything I
just said you still haven't answered my
question
the market on the left looks at fouchi
as God as he can't do anything wrong and
they're so afraid to criticize him the
only person that did they kicked him out
of his party and his family even pretty
much disowned him his name is Robert F
Kennedy Jr I don't did you read the
fouchy book he wrote on uh uh did you
read the case against Anthony fouchy
yeah if you read it the first words in
that book are a quote from me the first
words that the uh the pharmaceutical
industry has taken over the knowledge
that doctors have in the introduction
what did you think about the what did
you think about the book on things he
said about Fouch I think that uh I think
that uh RFK is a very smart guy he works
really hard and he gets a lot of things
right and but in my opinion he doesn't
have a firm grasp of his own desire to
prove his point his confirmation such as
such as uh when he was on Joe Rogan show
in in June he he cited an article uh
that said uh that he claimed said that
vaccinations have never saved any lives
and I looked that up because that didn't
sound right and it's not right he cited
the article wrong and but R RFK Jr works
so fast that it's very hard to keep up
with him in real time so nobody can
debate him and I don't blame people for
not debating him because he's bringing
in new data if he would um stick to the
data to what he said on the Rogan
show then I think I'd debate him if if
he was locked into to that position what
does that even mean though I don't
understand what you just said right
there because so you're now probably
bringing up that Dr Paul hotz was not
willing to talk to RFK cuz that was
going on and I remember that yeah what
what do you mean if he sticks to what he
said to
no no um uh you put the two things
together it's impossible to debate RFK
real time because he's a voluminous
reader and he's interpreting things
sometimes when he interprets articles
there's bias that he interprets the
article to confirm what his preious but
you guys do that more than he does who
am I you guys do you mean the opposite
side right everybody does so if you if
you no time out I I spent a lot of time
in litigation okay you cannot do that in
litigation you'll get torn apart by the
drug company lawyers by the drug company
lawyers has has any drug has so has
Anthony fouchy ever said anything
incorrect when it comes on to citing
studies and research and gain a function
and any of that stuff has he ever said
anything incorrect has any big Pharma
company sued Anthony
fouchi uh I don't think so but why not
though he's because his bias is selling
covid vaccines that's exactly the point
so that's the part where that's exactly
the point I'm trying to make how is it
that the guy that's been in he's been a
director of NIH for how many years 36
years 38 years I don't know what the
numbers a long ass time right he's been
there for a long time so why is he so
protected why is he so protected why why
is he so protected that the guy is
pretty much they should make
Untouchables too and have him be in a
cast with a handful of other people cuz
he's
Untouchable I don't blame you for having
that opinion I have some of that opinion
but I think what what fouchi has been
doing has been good for the
pharmaceutical industry I agree and I
think we I I want to take this up a
level because you guys are talking about
the uh prospectuses and and how the the
financial companies the banks and so
forth their job is to maximize their
profits and they make these prospectuses
and if they don't tell the truth they're
in deep trouble by law by law yeah
correct the pharmaceutical industry is
different than that because their job is
to maximize their profits just like the
money guys and they're doing it D they
buy they buy guys like him out and they
can't buy an RFK out and that's why you
know can you imagine an RFK as an
independent guy who the mainstream media
didn't want to have him on he got all
the traction that he got from doing
podcast right this guy's father got
assassinated and his uncle got
assassinated and his father would have
been a president and his uncle was a
president and they were probably the
most beloved anti-establishment
Democratic president family of all time
you know they fought against the
establishment today's Democrats don't
fight The Establishment they defend the
establishment it's a very weird dynamic
so I feel like his family changed and
they became establishment and to me RFK
is like listen guys I'm following my
dad's Legacy I'm following my father's
my uncle's Legacy so to me when he went
around talking and nobody wanted to
debate him it's exactly why you said
because he's so well read that his
opponents fear Him they know he will
school them that's not fair Patrick you
don't think so that's not fair okay push
back I'm open to
it a I agree with about 70% of what RFK
has to say he's a smart guy he's
articulate he's committed and that 70% I
respect
tremendously B he controls the any
debate because he's read more articles
far and wide but he's not censoring
himself enough if he would have uh fact
Checkers to check what he the positions
he's taking before he goes public with
it then there'd be something there
perfect so what how about we do this you
just made a basis for it right so so are
you friends with Paul Hotes are you in
communication okay so would you debate
an RFK in a long from podcast let's just
say with Joe you go on Joe because both
of you guys have been there as well and
there's a two or three fact Checker
sitting there the entire time
factchecking you and factchecking RFK
would you be open to that no because you
can't go fast enough this is what I was
saying before but I I took it out of
context and you didn't understand it he
went on uh Joe Rogan show I think last
June M and he made a number of cases
okay I haven't thoroughly analyzed the
whole tape but I saw one instance where
he was definitely wrong what I'm saying
is that's his position as of June uh
2023 right if he wanted to debate based
on those positions don't bring in a 100
new articles that you've interpreted
that nobody can possibly check in real
time because it takes hours uh but if he
stayed like a like in a deposition when
I was doing litigation the lawyers would
say you can only talk about what's in
the four corners of this
report if what he said on Rogan if the
claims he made on Rogan were the was a
report and he had to stay within the
four corners of that
report then I'd debate him that it just
would tell me the other gu your opponent
is more prepared and well read than you
no no he's reading far and wide but he's
the one who's the Arbiter of what it
says it doesn't you can't read
everything Patrick this you're right I
agree no no I don't I don't dispute that
so he's out in the lead he's very fast
and he's very
smart but he's looking for things that
confirm his biases and he's making some
mistakes yeah I mean you're saying he's
making mistakes SE so okay so you say
7030 RFK where do you put fouchy at if
you can put him like that 7030 where do
you put fouchy when he talks
I I don't want to put a number on it but
I is it higher or do you trust fouchy
more than RFK no no no no I've seen this
fall apart no no I think I think fouchy
is exposed to real risk here um how he's
protected RFK is not protected I I don't
how is RFK protected who protects RFK
honestly nobody nobody nobody but it uh
nobody who protects fouchi right there's
an entire institution that protects fou
doc he's protected by mainstream media
celebrities big Pharma yes do you see
who the bully here is we're we're on the
same page it's all going to break
whatever your issue is whether it's
Republican Democrat uh in government out
government I'm establishment anti- I'm
not I'm not at all Republican Democrat
Chuck Schumer and Mitch McConnell are
best friends that this that's not a
democratic Republican thing that's
exactly best
they're just given stories how how close
those two are that's right this is not
this is not it's it's about Pharma
making money got to get our eyes on that
but I get that but I think the part
where people look away is you know on
the for example okay everybody we none
of us had a clue who this guy was except
for people that were in the space if
you're in the space okay or people that
were maybe older above 60 and you
remember in the 80s with AIDS yeah and
you're like okay I remember thisy guy's
name was Ron and AIDS where you know
that drug and you know they were selling
the nzt and then you know and by the way
later on there was a movie a and the
protees Inhibitors nzt is from the movie
Limitless but they got the name nzt from
a that fouchy anyways so you're like
okay I don't know that okay maybe he's a
noble guy and then all of a sudden
people are coming out that work with
them and here's what he want okay I mean
everybody talks about everybody
fine I don't need to buy no but there's
some yeah you guys just don't like the
guy you're just hating on the guy it's
like oh no this guy could be a dark guy
that's bot that's defending everybody
motive now we got to find out what this
guy's really all about then everybody
flipped because the hypocrisy kept
showing up with who this guy really was
all about so now let let's go to a
different part fines okay pharmaceutical
and fines I pulled up how many what type
of fines these guys have paid okay if
you want to pull the supp biggest findes
uh at the highest level is $3 billion
that's Glo Smith the Klein and this was
again off label promotion Kickbacks same
thing they paid for most of them are the
same thing fiser in 2009 2.3 billion
same thing off Lael promotion Kickbacks
John let me just say something I
consulted to the FBI in the Department
of Justice on that case in 09 yep really
yeah they came to you or you went to
them I went to them oh wow I had I did
civil litigation it was uh most of that
was about a drug called bextra which was
like Vio
um and I was in civil litigation about
that there were 10,000 people it wasn't
as big a drug as Vio there were I think
47,000 people in the Vio litigation and
I knew about what happened and I called
the doj Blind and uh said I I know
something about this drug but I can't
tell you because I've signed the
confidentiality agreement and uh uh they
sent out a uh I don't know if it was a
federal Marshal to deliver a federal
subpoena to my house and they they said
you will be at FBI headquarters at such
and such a date and you will bring your
computer and I went and I told them what
I knew what I had learned in in civil
litigation uh they keep their cards
close to their chest they were uh really
up to date they they were crackerjack
lawyers um and that was the end of the
discussion and six months later I read
in the paper that there was a $ 1.1 N5
billion wow fraud case that that fiser
PL guilty to fraud and uh they paid this
fine now a very important fact here is
that the fizer
pled to a felony in this case but fizer
didn't take the hit a subsidiary took
the hit and that's the way this game is
played so when these big fines are Meed
out by the Department of Justice the
companies have subsidiaries take the hit
so the parent company isn't at risk of
getting um from Medicare and so the the
CEOs don't go to jail and the drug
companies aren't at risk of um losing
their uh Medicare business um and
there's very little um there's very
little disincentive not to try to get
away with this because rarely do the
fines add up to the amount of ill ill
gotten profits I wonder and by the way
there's multiple billion let me see 1
two 3 four there's five finds that Eli
Lily Abbot Laboratories Johnson and
Johnson fizer o these guys paid that's
over a billion dollars and he got a
bunch of other ones here as well am Jin
you know another Glo tap Sereno Merc
Puro at 601 I can list all of these guys
right they're getting fined but to them
they're sitting there saying I don't
really care you know we sold this
pharmaceutical for so much money Pennies
on a dollar to make it we're selling it
for $5,000 we'll pay the fine go ahead
if it makes you happy with with what
happened the last four years do you
think we're going to have something
coming up where it say
actual accountability record-breaking
type of find that we've not seen before
or you think nothing's going to happen
to these guys I don't see it happening I
see it's a game it's just business it's
business as usual unless people go to
jail or unless companies are barred from
participating in Medicare it's not going
to stop their job is to maximize their
profits and if there's a$2 billion fine
so be it are you are you following this
new thing they're talking about at the
Davos the disease X that World economic
Forum talked about it could kill 20
times more than covid-19 have you
followed any of this or no yeah they
just started talking about it this week
is this disease X that uh it just came
out a few hours ago world leaders to
meet discuss threat of hypothetical
disease X pandemic in Davos that could
kill 20 times as amount of people as
others How concerned are you for someone
that you know has been in this space you
know you said your age earlier 75 and
you had a procedure last year where
you're dealing with a cardiologist and
you know doing certain things to you
where you were kind of worried saying
this could be it for me how worried are
you of the next pandemic of the next
virus that can be deadly does that at
all concern you or do you think it's
just they're trying to sell fear porn to
us to find ways to sell us another Pharm
or another shot it's both okay it's both
I'm worried I mean um I don't know where
Co came from it might well have come
from the lab it may have well have come
from gain of function research it might
not it could have come from natural
sources and you got to worry about that
stuff but I'm equally worried about the
pharmaceutical companies exaggerating
the risk and tinkering with the threats
so that they can make more money if if
if the Pharm if the profits of the
pharmaceutical company this goes back to
what to the uh filings with the SEC and
the financial perspectives if that
doesn't get straightened out and if the
pharmaceutical industry doesn't have to
present its real data to doctors and the
public this stuff is going to keep going
on because their job is to maximize
their profits and as long as they're not
held accountable by anybody they're
going to keep doing what they're doing
and I write a book you know it's it's
got to be five years behind the times by
the time it gets into print and the
litigation takes 10 years and it takes a
long time but um we're not making
progress Farm is moving faster in their
Direction then we can catch up to them
who's who is so so who is we that can do
something about it is it a pro because
to me you know I sat there and I said
okay where can you hurt these guys where
maybe they're going to wake up and be
like oh that's actually going to be
felt first thing you think about is okay
what if they can't advertise on TV
anymore what if they can't pay a Travis
Kelce $20 million what if they can't do
something like that does that hurt their
pockets a lot because when you look at
their budget about how much money they
spend every year on Advertising Sky
Rizzy $383 Million last year you know
Ren vog you know however way you
pronounce these words $351 million you
know dupixent $37 million I can give all
the they're spending so much money
advertising every year do you think if
they stopped and said listen moving
forward no more the only country can do
it as in New Zealand we're also agreeing
it's not going to happen we are a
capitalist Nation but you're kind of
messing up you did not gain a lot of
credibility during Co no more
advertising for you guys is that enough
of a pain to these guys I I don't think
it's going to happen a good lawyer uh
explained to me that our first amendment
is different than the first amendment in
other countries and because there you
you mentioned it before because there
are beneficial uses of drugs unlike
cigarettes um You Can't Ban the
advertising but that doesn't matter
because you could make the
advertisements say how much better Sky
Rizzy or any drug not to pick on Sky
Rizzy is better than the best available
therapy and how many people you have to
treat to have one person get a result
that you couldn't get with the other
drugs and how much it costs in the total
drugs that are sold for uh uh how much
it cost to have one person improve you
could put all that into an ad so it was
genuinely educational so you don't have
to take on a constitutional issue you
can just make them present data that is
is the rational data that doctors and
patients need to make a good decision
and we don't have a government we were
talking about this before we don't have
a government organization that does that
but you could do it if they want to
advertise then you you got to tell the
truth they would need to be an
organization that can't take a penny
from a pharmaceutical company you know
what I'm saying like it almost needs to
be something where uh because
immediately who's going to be knocking
on their doors hi this is John Doe I'm a
lobbyist representing XYZ come we love
your work yeah and that's happening
again with another lobbyist absolutely
be like the registry for LMI and it's
taken over by the Alzheimer's
Association so I I I I think the answer
to the question is we're in a deephole
here we we've got uh 1.1 million
Americans are dying above and beyond the
deaths in the other wealthy countries
because our Health and healthc Care is
so inferior 1.1 million people a year
that's 3,00 a day it's like a 911 every
day and for this health care and health
we're spending an excess $2.3 trillion a
year I know you're worried about the
military industrial budget collusion and
the military budget I'm all with you
we're wasting three times more than the
entire military budget and our health is
just falling further and further behind
it's a national crisis mainstream media
won't cover it it's a I mean it's like
9911 dominated our cont ious for years
and years this is happening every day to
Americans and we've got to address it no
we're we're we're on the same page here
with uh um we're on the same page here
with this you know we said you sit there
and you think about what direction we're
going right now and all these different
fears they sell us about hey you got to
be careful with this hey you got to be
careful with that I'm yeah you know what
you're imposing yourself too much on me
uh you by the way from your
eyes specific individual or or
organization okay who who do you think
is enemy the state meaning if you were
to say well I think uh World Health
Organization doesn't have the best in
mind for us or NIH or fouchy or big
Pharma or this or that who would be the
ones that the average person watching is
saying I got to watch those guys who
would you say that top you got to watch
them because they're bad or because
they're they may be helpful both well I
think the World Health Organization is
generally on the right side of things
they don't have access to perfect data
but I don't see them World Health
Organization is on the right side of
things I think so you think so do you do
you think uh World economic Forum Claus
Schwab and SE Rose they're on the right
side of
things uh I don't know about them do you
think Cedros Tedros who runs a a world
uh uh Health Organization he's on the
right side of things I think they're
generally on the right side of things
they they would say they do say that 80%
of uh cardiovascular disease can be
prevented by lifestyle modification and
um being able to participate in a
healthy lifestyle they're not trying to
get everybody on statins and and the
other uh cholesterol lowering drugs
they're they're taking a genuine Public
Health perspective about how can we
optimally improve health and uh not uh
having our go-to position being relying
on
Pharmaceuticals who else who who else
good or bad to look out
for I think public citizen does a good
job of uh analyzing uh what's going on
in uh American Medicine
uh and there are organizations
um uh like um the Therapeutics
initiative out of uh uh the University
of British Columbia does a great job of
analyzing medicines as best they can
because they they don't get the data
they're not in litigation um so there
are organizations farmed out does a good
job there are organizations that are
trying to look at this critically but
we're shut out they and I are shut out
of the mainstream media and we're
missing all there is is this enormous
Financial push from Pharma to convince
people and their doctors that the way to
Better Health and more fulfilling lives
is through better
biotechnology and that's just not the
case but some people benefit I benefited
from better
biotechnology but on the whole we're not
spending our money the right way we
should be spending uh 20% of our health
has to do with health care but we're
spending um almost all of our money on
drugs and devices and and that's not the
way to get better health we're letting
the market allocate the research funds
so that 96% of the information that
doctors get is about drugs and devices
and 4% is how to make Americans
healthier we we need research and and
the reason for that is because the
research about how to make Americans
healthier doesn't make money for anybody
it's going to cost the pharmaceutical
Industries money and we need some way to
get the knowledge that doctors believe
is the appropriate range of knowledge to
represent what the doctors need to know
about how to make people and their
communities healthier would disagree
with that a little bit to it sounded
like you were done so I apologize if you
I just cut you off there um there is
going to be a rational player in our
White House at one point and that
rational player is going to look at the
uh Social Security and Medicare and
those trust funds that are bound to wear
out right and and and to go broke and
they're going to be looking around and
saying how do we get lifestyle
information to seniors so that
everything in life isn't just well the
health that'll go to my doctor and get a
pill you there's be people talking about
it about how do we how do we get ahead
of lifestyle and you know why are we
allowing soda in schools a lot of good
things are going to come out of this to
say hey you know what you know uh
overweight as a kid is overweight as
adult as obese as a senior as as a
diabetic patient and you're on
somebody's spreadsheet today because
that's a good thing oh wow was empe
we'll take care of you right well
somebody's going to be in the White
House and somebody's going to say hey we
got to get lifestyle
is a very sensible investment and it's
going to save a lot of this social
security Medicare so we don't go further
into debt we can take it somebody's just
standing out there let me go to Pat's
question back to you who do you think
obviously it's you you're talking about
the media knocks me down the mainstream
media well the mainstream media is
taking pharmaceutical ads so so I'm sure
they're told not to cover your book and
not to interview you okay you know to me
that makes sense there's no conspiracy
there it's a left right analysis of an
economic decision who who are the
enemies of Pharma when Pharma looks out
there who do they feel are their enemies
who like who the Pharma fears right who
do they fear that's good list who are
they yeah Pharma fears this discussion
happening more broadly for what reason
specifically we've covered a lot of
things be for the reason that they now
control what doctors believe is good
health care and they do not want to
relinquish that so data data going
public that everybody can inspect peer
reviews that are true peer reviews going
back to data no we don't want that okay
what else don't they want an an
epidemiologically balanced research
agenda they don't want that so they
don't want rules and and constructs into
the into the research and everything
back there well well not rules and
constructs but uh instead of spending
96% of our research money as allocated
by the market because that's where the
profit is the return on maximum return
on investment we should be allocating
our research money based on what
Americans need to be healthier and they
don't want that mhm that's what I meant
and I used the wrong words but that's ex
so so far let's see what else he's going
to say Tom go forward what else would
you say to that list okay ask the
question again what what does the big
farmer fear the most they fear anything
that's going to cut into their profits
and any politician who takes a stance
is going to come up against enormous
resistance by the from the drug
companies two-thirds of the legislators
on both in both parties take money from
the drug companies this is not a
partisan issue Republicans I fully agree
yeah yeah and and I hope that your
listeners come away from this not
thinking did the left win or did the
right win that's we lost if they're
thinking that the only thing we saw is
the left promoted the vaccine like no
other mainstream late night celebrity
Talent Hollywood Sports they they
promoted like no other like they were
hardcore preacher pastors there was a
religion of taking the vaccine and they
profits promoting it Patrick I agree
without qualification I agree but it has
to do with pharmaceutical profits that
is where the breaks are off and until
there is enough public understanding in
the in the healthc Care Professionals
and non-healthcare professionals about
how this is disserving the American
people there are 1.1 million excess
deaths were wasting the equivalent of
the federal budget deficit every year on
Healthcare and until the people the
people um bring that to the public
Consciousness Farmers money is going to
control the debate So when you say the
people were out marketing Co I agree
with you 100% And if they're going to
Market Co better through Republicans
they'll do that and if they're going to
do Democrats they'll do that they're
just interested M they don't care who it
is they don't care they just want to
promote the product right I agree with
you right and what we got to do going
forward is get rid of this Left Right
dichotomy and figure what's going to be
right for the American people and how
can we get Americans talking about
what's the way to handle this we've got
a crisis do you think our patent laws
you know how they kind of kept going
back and forth changing it it used to be
20 years the the two senators or
congressmen they Lo one of them was a
republican one was a them they L her to
14 years then they brought her back up
to 20 years and then you know how
they're able to by manipulation of
Evergreen and changing slight Fu laws
you know few things about the patent or
the drug to extend another 18 years on
patent you think Pat patent laws need to
be changed you think Congress needs to
take a look at the patent laws yes I do
and the patent thickets I mean the
pharmaceutical folks are are light years
ahead of who's ever trying to catch them
on these issues um the drug price
negotiations they'll do a little bit but
they're mostly for show and Pharma is
crying like they're going to you know
get their privates busted no it's going
to cost in real terms the money far is
going to lose on the price negotiations
is going to cost us about two uh
significantly effective drugs over the
next 30 Years but they're arguing that
we're going to kill them we're going to
kill them with the price of insulin
being
$35 that insulin is no better than the
cheapest insulin for type 2 diabetics
but we can't even have that discussion
well I love the fact that you're going
around and I respect you for pushing the
envelope questioning even some of your
own you know positions that you may have
over the years as somebody that's a
reputable doctor beloved doctor doctor
where you're at and coming out and
saying hey here's what I think is going
on here's what I think is wrong with the
industry I don't think enough people are
doing what you're doing and I applaud
you for and I got a lot of respect for
you doing that we need more men and
women like you in your space that are
willing to do that cuz it's not easy CU
a part of it's kind of like what are you
doing guys this is our little stick that
we have don't do that don't put expose
us like no guys I'm doing this for
integrity I'm at a face of my life that
I'm not doing this for money I really
want to find a way to impact the Next
Generation and I respect that I think we
need more more more people like that
thank you the book sickening link will
be below R put it in the chat in the
description in every place that you can
have how big Pharma broke American
Healthcare and how we can repair it I am
all about studying this topic especially
from somebody who's qualified
questioning things who's going to give
you and I a different perspective if you
haven't yet order this copy click on the
link below go order the copy of
sickening um doc appreciate you for
coming in once again really enjoyed it
thank you for having me Patrick if uh
but for people like you this information
stays in a soundproof chamber we want to
make sure the world is reading and
investigating because they may see an
angle that we're not even thinking about
ourselves thank you so much everybody
take care bye-bye
bye-bye